et puis l'actualité aussi aujourd'hui
c'était les prix littéraires le prix
médicis étranger qui a été attribué à
alexandre zinoviev pour son roman
l'avenir radieux et puis le médicis tout
court attribué à georges perec pour
l'emploi la vie mode d'emploi chez
hachette énorme livre de 600 pages
jaunes elle tire un livre c'est qu à
vivre dans un monde où il ya déjà
beaucoup de livres qui ont compté
filière j'écris dérive parce que j'ai
été enthousiasmé par par joss par melvil
par kafka par par calvino par marina
tubes et jeu mais j'aime y fait des
sortes dommage génie à l'intérieur de
mon livre je me suis servi de phrases
qu'ils ont écrit des deux personnages
qui l'ont fait vivre même en continuant
leur vie la vie mode d'emploi c'est un
peu un titre dérisoire n'y a pas de mode
d'emploi pour la vie là on essaye d'en
trouver un et puis finalement non le
seul qu'est-ce qui l'emportent chez vous
de la curiosité des autres et de la
recherche littéraires je crois que c'est
les deux sont non sens
j'essaie de voir les choses autrement
j'essaye de montrer les choses les gens
comme si je les avais jamais vu je pense
que ça donne quelque chose qui est
je crois que c'est ça qui fait qu'il y a
il ya cette espèce de petit maquis c'est
qui vient dans le livre qui fait qu'ils
se développent pas qu'il est au début il
est un peu difficile à lire et après il
se rendit grossit et puis on est dedans
roulait bien dedans on est bien dedans
comme un prunier à la mer c'est comme ça
exactement